so why is this deal important that this
happens my wife and I Jessica uh we've
been trying for a child for about 17
years and then a couple years ago I
decided we would go to Ukraine and Har a
surrogacy but due to my job I'm not
allowed to go to Ukraine anymore so it's
your baby mhm so I've got to get in
there get this project done and get out
again and then you're going to get your
baby get my baby and then I can give up
my job because they won't let me go to
Ukraine so you needed this deal more
than anything right now how confident
are you in this deal as an investment
100% confident it that's good I'm glad
you're confident because I am confident
too so that is approved my friend thank
you so
much